kulturschock ibm giuseppe es klingt zwar
verrückt aber statt ibm kompatiblen
computer also windows rechnern werden
seit kurzem max bei ibm eingesetzt jetzt
bei pixum science fiction heute mal was
aus dem bereich wirtschafts bzw
organisations wissenschaft wer 1984
vorausgesagt hätte das ibm am ersten
juni 2015 damit beginnt seine pc
infrastruktur auf macs umzustellen wäre
wahrscheinlich sofort eingeliefert
worden 984 war ibm der böse big brother
und ridley scott der berühmte regisseur
drehte zum verkaufsstart des macs einen
legendären werbespot in dem ein hammer
in einen riesigen bildschirm mit eben
diesem big brother ibm geworfen wird
eine kampfansage aber genau dieser kampf
scheint jetzt gewonnen worden zu sein
seit 2005 10 haben die mitarbeiter von
ibm die möglichkeit statt eines pcs
beziehungsweise ibm kompatiblen computer
also windows computers einen mac als
dienstrechner zu bestellen
die auswirkungen sind beeindruckend
inzwischen sind mehr als 90.000 max bei
ibm angeschafft worden jede woche werden
1.300 neue rechner angeliefert ibm hat
wer mehr weltweit mehr als 600.000
laptops im einsatz
die jetzt stück für stück durch max
ersetzt werden wenn die entwicklung so
weitergeht ist abzusehen wann ibm fast
nur max als arbeitsplatzrechner hat und
tatsächlich sieht es sehr danach aus 73
prozent der mitarbeiter wünschen sich
als nächsten computer einen mac schon
jetzt gehört ibm zu den größten kunden
bei apple und wird mit 100.000 max ende
2016 der größte unternehmenskunde von
apple sein eigentlich war dieses projekt
dazu gedacht den mitarbeitern eine
angenehme arbeitsatmosphäre zu bieten
indem sie das system auf dem sie
arbeiten wollen selbst wählen können so
sollte ibm auch attraktiver für die top
talente der branche werden ziel war es
mit diesem workplaces serviceprogramm
eine neue unternehmenskultur zu schaffen
die these technologie kann gestohlen
werden unternehmenskultur aber nicht die
folgen sind aber weit reichender denn
nicht nur die zufriedenheit der
mitarbeiter ist gestiegen bei max
liegt sie bei 91 sondern ibm hat
festgestellt dass der einsatz von max
und ios devices um ein vielfaches
günstiger ist als der einsatz von ibm
kompatiblen computer und android devices
das fängt schon bei der anschaffung an
macs sind zwar grundsätzlich teurer als
herkömmliche pcs aber ihr
wiederverkaufswert ist deutlich höher
als der eines windows rechners die
größte kostenersparnis entsteht jedoch
bei der betreuung der max im gegensatz
zur ibm kompatiblen pcs auf denen zuerst
einen festplatten image eingespielt
werden muss können max direkt an die
mitarbeiter ausgeliefert werden auch die
weitere wartung ist vollkommen
unkompliziert im gegensatz zu windows
rechnern können die max nämlich direkt
über die apple server upgedatet werden
das ist bei windows pcs laut dem
präsident für workplace eservice
fletcher provinz nicht der fall er sagt
sogar dass es bei windows rechnern
günstiger ist einen neuen computer zu
kaufen als ein neues system zu
installieren der ansatz den er verfolgte
war der wenn ich ein smartphone habe
dann muss ich ja auch kein festplatten
images vor der verwendung aufspielen
warum kann ich einen computer nicht
genauso wie ein smartphone manager
genauso funktionieren max im gegensatz
zu ibm kompatiblen pcs sind sie so
unproblematisch zu betreuen wie
smartphones zudem sind sie mit nahezu
jeder software kompatibel
die wbm verwendet wird das sind rund
3000 anwendungen 78 davon sind
problematisch und nur 42 davon laufen
tatsächlich nicht auf einem mac was aber
nur sehr sehr wenige mitarbeiter
betrifft ein weiterer nicht zu
unterschätzender vorteil der max ist sie
sind für die mitarbeiter mit der
höchsten sicherheitsstufe einsetzbar
das heißt sie erfüllen die gleichen
sicherheitsstandards wie die bisher
eingesetzten linux rechner windows pcs
sind dafür nicht zugelassen sie sind zu
unsicher
aber auch im laufenden betrieb bieten
die max erhebliche vorteile
so rufen mac user nur halb so oft die
hotline an und bei lediglich fünf
prozent dieser fälle ist service vor ort
nötig bei herkömmlichen pc sind es 27
prozent
zudem sinkt die nutzung des supports in
prozent auf die war auf der basis der
installierten max kontinuierlich waren
es am anfang noch 76 prozent zur
portikus die benötigt wurden sind es
jetzt mit 32 prozent nur noch knapp die
hälfte
alles in allem kosten 100.000 windows
kompatible rechner für support software
auslieferungen usw
in einem zeitraum von vier jahren 57 3
millionen dollar mehr als max die kosten
sind damit dreimal höher als bei max und
das obwohl für das mcafee em-programm
neue head decks mit apple
spezialisierten neuen mitarbeitern
eingerichtet werden mussten sie wurden
aber mit dem entwicklerteam
zusammengelegt was auch zur steigerung
der effizienz beigetragen hat tritt
jetzt also ein problem auf oder am heck
des kit festgestellt dass etwas
verbessert werden kann
wird ein solcher fall direkt vom
entwicklerteam in die hand genommen
das hat zu veränderungen generell bei
ibm geführt nicht nur alle apple
relevanten webseiten im internet sondern
zahlreiche andere programme und seiten
wurden durch diesen kulturwechsel
verändert und stark vereinfacht die max
verändern also tatsächlich weit über das
gesteckte ziel hinaus die
unternehmenskultur bei ibm ein weiterer
punkt ist die sicherheit während für
windows 7 im jahr 2015 135 system
patches installiert werden mussten waren
es für max nur 31 bei mclaren 11
sicherheitsrelevant bei windows 7 waren
es 86 für die it-abteilung heißt dass
max müssen 104 mal weniger betreut
werden als herkömmliche pcs auch bei
android zeigt sich im vergleich zu ios
ein signifikanter unterschied bei der
security um eine unbekannte
sicherheitslücke dort aufzufinden und
ein schadprogramm dafür zu entwickeln
kostet das im darknet laut fletcher
provinz zwischen 10 und 100.000 dollar
für ios liegt der preis bei ungefähr 1,5
millionen dollar es ist also allein
schon finanziell extrem aufwändig ios zu
hacken unter anderem deswegen werden bei
ibm auch bei den mobile devices mehr ios
geräte eingesetzt von den rund 160.000
geräten sind 66 prozent
ios 44 android und 0 4 prozent
blackberry geräte ist wirklich verrückt
dass der haut
denn von apple nach 30 jahren dessen
technologie übernimmt und das alles
eigentlich nicht um geld einzusparen und
das bessere system zu nutzen sondern um
einen kulturwechsel im konzert konzern
einzuleiten die folge aber sind weit
reichen nicht nur die unternehmenskultur
ändert sich sondern eben auch die kosten
sinken
die mitarbeiter sind zufriedener und
alles in allem läuft der it-bereich
weitaus besser ein ergebnis das wohl
selbst apple fans so nicht vorhergesagt
hätten ja wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dem einen oder anderen könnte das
vielleicht nicht bei dem könnte es nicht
der fall gesagt lass mir gerne einen
daumen nach oben da oder ein kostenloses
abo dafür hier oben klicken und wenn ihr
hier klickt hier unten kommt er zu einem
video in dem wir uns in einem anderen
wirtschaftsthema stichwort tipp
beschäftigen schreibt mir eure meinung
zum heutigen thema gerne in die
kommentare
dann werde ich heftig mitdiskutieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran